when an author writes the original
screenplay
he has only himself to please when he
adapts one he has to please the author
of the original work the producer who
engages him to write the script the
director wants to reread that's why some
writers spend more time on a couch than
at their word processors but it's all
worth it when they give us scripts like
the five nominated for Best Screenplay
based on a material from another medium
yeah
Stephen zillion for awakenings from the
book by honor dr. Oliver Sacks
Michael Blake for Dances with Wolves
from his own novel Nicholas Pileggi
Martin Scorsese for Goodfellas and wives
traveling through the trilogy
Donnell D Westlake for The Grifters from
the book by Jim Thompson
Nicholas Kazan or reversal of fortune
based on the book by Anna districts the
Oscar goes to
Michael Blake for dancers
I had intended Doris where are you come
up here I had intended if I was
fortunate enough to win this magnificent
award to direct my remarks to young
people that I care about a lot all over
the world and I thought I should have
someone come and help me do that so this
is my friend Doris leader charge who was
played a critical role in our film Doris
is going to help me out
she's from rosebud South Dakota my
success began when I started to read
books
wah wah wah hey doc doc oh oh da ill he
where dreams come out of books we humbly
hannah wat be a doll and the dream that
came to me was to do something
beneficial for as many people as I could
humbly wanna blue hockey here oh yeah oh
oh a choc ya'll watching the miracle of
Dances with Wolves is that it proves
this kind of dream can come true
- gosh crap you want sugar money - Tonka
Oh Bochy alquiler boy humble I cannot
hold you each I can hold on to your
dreams boy humbly can I go lose some fat
don't let anyone take them away doing a
cheeky cap ok ok SHINee never give up
bleach at their use of their well again
my sincere affection and love to Kevin
Costner and Jim Wilson and to three
poets who inspire me all the time exceed
Cervenka Doug not and Jocelyn Heaney
goodnight
the place an Academy Award nominee for
an officer a gentleman and terms of
endearment this Debra Winger
go to the movie and when Robert DeNiro
embraces Ruth Nelson I defy anyone with
a heartbeat to keep a dry eye I'm
talking about a scene in the fourth
nominated Best Picture it's the true
story of a shy doctors efforts to
resurrect life for patients written off
by others as the Living Dead
believe it or not it's funny and it's
heartwarming and inspiring and
ultimately uplifting here is a taste of
awakenings